it's interesting to hear this number
more than 80% of the country is waking
up to below freezing temperatures
bone-chilling cold stretches all the way
from the Gulf Coast to New England the
south is still reeling from yesterday's
deadly weather now this storm dumped
several inches of snow on Southern State
not accustomed to these harsh wintry
conditions extreme cold along with icy
roads are blamed for at least 10 deaths
including an eight month-old baby
the massive system dumped snow all the
way from Louisiana to Maine yesterday
parts of New York State and North
Carolina got up to a foot Kris Van
Cleave is in Greensboro North Carolina
among the most hard hit places Chris
good morning good cold morning from
Greensboro North Carolina as nearly
eight inches of snow is falling here
many people well they thought they were
gonna get a lot less so they went to
work only to have the state's governor
tell them to turn around and go home
by then we were trying to make our way
here watching cars spin out all around
us a wintry mix of snow wind and cold
led to icy chaos on the roads throughout
the South Wednesday an ice rink out here
in less than 24 hours the North Carolina
Highway Patrol says it handled 1600
crashes in Houston drivers would do
anything to get out of the miles of icy
traffic here going the wrong way down an
on-ramp scares me because I go to slide
it was a different picture in Atlanta
where normally clogged streets were
nearly desolate as around 2 inches of
snow brought the city to a standstill in
Columbus Indiana a driver was rescued
from this upside-down car after he hit
ice and plunged into a river not even
NASCAR drivers were immune racer Daniel
Suarez shared pictures on Twitter of his
Lexus stuck in the snow and Dale
Earnhardt jr. warned people to stay off
the roads in North Carolina after he
crashed into a tree the winter storm
prompted dozens of school districts to
close Wednesday with many remaining
closed today
like in New Orleans where temperatures
in the city dipped to 21 degrees
Wednesday breaking the record set in
1977 got jackets thermal clothes old and
everything oh you can put on it's all
you can put on know exactly how he feels
there was about six degrees this morning
here in Greensboro it's gonna warm up
into the 40s and by the weekend
hit the 50s that'll be the case up and
down the East Coast New York will be
into the 50s for the first time in over
a week so this snow is not gonna be here
very long John Chris thanks